[Musique]
nous sommes le 2 mars 2017 bonsoir et
bienvenue pour cette édition du 7 8 les
invités émission dédiée à celles et ceux
qui font l'actualité dans le département
voici le sommaire conception et
développement et des véhicules de la
marque au losange le technocentre à
guyancourt est au coeur du travail de
renault il est aussi l'un des sites les
plus actifs sur le plan économique pour
saint quentin en yvelines rencontre avec
son directeur philippe à brice montier
dans quelques instants et puis le est
19e printemps à des poètes se déroule en
ce moment avec la thématique de
l'afrique mise en lumière 36 rendez vous
prévu à saint quentin en yvelines
invités notamment samira negrouche en
plateau avec nous bonsoir et bienvenue
bonsoir également à jacques fournier
vous êtes le directeur d itinéraire
poétique qui chapote sur saint quentin
en yvelines toute cette opération qui
sera justement déjà un mot sur cette
édition vous annoncez lectures
expositions rencontres spectacles pour
découvrir je cite un la parole portée
par des poètes venus d'un continent en
pleine mutation
à découvrir une très grande richesse oui
on va essayer de faire de montrer que
voilà ce continent multiples protéiforme
dans ces langues dans ses son histoire
dans ses écritures et complètement
méconnu
si on parle si on parle de poètes
africains on citera en premier
inévitablement senghor jean-denis
grandes partitions d'oeuvres qui ont
même été écrite en français et en langue
française et on oubliera aussi toute la
richesse de l'afrique du nord on
oubliera toute la richesse de l'afrique
subsaharienne
alors nous on s'est attachés
principalement comme on le fait souvent
avec les itinéraires politique aux
poètes de langue française
prioritairement voilà en allant chercher
des poètes des afriques de l'afrique
noire principalement de l'afrique de
l'afrique blanche de vivant en afrique
même ou de la diaspora africaine vivant
en france en belgique parce que ils ont
aussi une langue qui s'est nourri de ce
que l'on peut nous de ce qu'ils ont pu
prendre deux de ce que nous avons pu
leur apporter et de ce qu'ils ont
accepté de tout cela le printemps des
poètes c'est en ce moment et c'est
jusqu'au 25 mars il ya une riche
programmation vous l'avez compris sur
saint quentin en yvelines il ya un site
internet pour connaître tous les détails
même si on va essayer de donner quelques
rendez-vous au cours des prochaines
minutes
samira negrouche j'aimerais avoir votre
regard aussi sur une telle initiative
une telle opération
on est dans un moment si on reste dans
la politique dans l'actualité de repli
sur soi aujourd'hui et la grâce à ce
printemps des poètes on va s'ouvrir on
va découvrir la richesse d'un continent
absolument un continent qui est très
souvent soit oublié soit stigmatisée on
oublie que c'est quand même la mère des
civilisations notre berceau à tous que
ce soit génétiquement au culturellement
un continent qui peut être une pour une
certaine partie de son histoire à s'est
transmis de façon orale mais qui
comporte aussi d écriture singulière
très forte très diverses qu'elle soit
francophone comme venait de le dire
jacques fournier mais également l'uso
phone anglophone est également dans des
langues qui sont très anciennes parmi
lesquels je citerai le tamazight puisque
je suis nord africaine vous écrivez en
français vous le disiez tout à l'heure
vous mettez en lumière principalement
les auteurs francophones qui écrivent en
français pourquoi ce choix du français
alors ce choix parce que c'est une
langue qui qui qui qui s'est développé
bien au delà des colonisations qui après
les indépendances est restée vivante
d'une manière différente d'une région à
une autre de l'afrique
en algérie par exemple c'est une langue
qui est encore enseigné à l'université
je suis de formation médicale
toutes les études scientifiques dans mon
pays se font en français donc on ne peut
pas demander à des personnes qui qui
sont formés intellectuellement dans une
langue d'écrire dans une autre langue
très souvent nous voient comme un pays
exclusivement arabophone ce n'est pas le
cas et au-delà de cela nous descendons
aussi d'une généalogie de littérature
algérienne ou maghrébine ou africaine de
langue française est un auteur né de ses
lectures forcément et des lectures des
aînés qui sont nés qui ont développé une
écriture à partir de leur imaginaire de
leur territoire de leur patrimoine
donc je ne serai pas la personne que je
suis aujourd'hui s'il n'y avait pas eu
kateb yacine et assia djebar
ou bien ratibi ou bien senghor ou bien
pire ago diop
il faut aussi savoir que cette langue
française nous lie rigon d'une autre
manière et elle est irrigué des langues
qui qui coexistent et qui évoluent dans
nos territoires
il faut savoir également que le
continent africain est un réceptacle et
comment dire est un terrain d'important
pour la langue française
jusqu'à demain je me rappelle plus des
chiffres mais me semble-t-il
il y aura demain plus de francophones en
afrique partout ailleurs dans le monde
jacques fournier qu'est ce qui vous
séduit dans le travail de femme ira dans
son écriture c'est aussi ce mariage d
influence oui ça m'ira en plus c'est une
grande voyageuse
c'est à dire que ça son écriture se
nourrit de tout ce qu'elle voit c'est
une éponge et c'est ça qui m'intéresse
aussi dans son dans la personne qu'elle
est que je connais depuis maintenant
quelques années puisque ça m'ira voilà
participé aux manifestations de la
maison de la poésie
dans une autre époque et je vais
proposer de revenir cette année d'être
l'invité d'honneur de ce printemps des
poètes sur 3,3 de semaine et sera
présente jusqu'au jusqu'au 18 mars la
dernière vainement dans lequel est
auquel elle interviendra et son écriture
moi m'a intéressé par ce qui m'intéresse
toujours parce que justement elle elle
cherche en impression que dans son
écriture elle est en train de rien et
rien n'est définitif il ya une recherche
les formes ne sont pas toujours les
mêmes d'un ensemble politique à l'autre
on vient on vient de faire publier aux
éditions mazette de gilles chevalet et
floriane fagots à plaisir le un livre de
de samira qui constituait de différentes
suites et ses suites ont chacune leur
identité et c'est ça aussi qui
m'intéresse c'est à dire que ça me
ramenez pas de ces poètes qui enferme la
poésie dans une forme et cette richesse
justement elle permet le dialogue elle
permet l échange et elle se nourrit des
de ce qu'on a appelé les printemps
arabes mais tout aussi de ceux de sa vie
personnelle de ses amours de ses
rencontres de ses déceptions de ces
voyages et quand samira est venue est
venu ans arrivé en france il ya quelques
temps elle m'a tout de suite dit voilà
j'ai rencontré un tête j'ai rencontré
une telle était la dnat j'ai rencontré
les lacets barre voilà des amis à elle
des gens qu'elle aime rencontrer parce
que c'est une éponge d'amitié et d'amour
l'esad intéresse beaucoup c'est pour
découvrir son travail on va être pris
par le temps mais quels sont les rendez
vous majeurs auxquels vous allez
participer
alors on va déjà cité le livre peut-être
samira le titre alors six arbres de
fortune autour de ma baignoire qui est
sorti hier aux éditions maze est
peut-être la première rencontre qui me
vient comme ça c'est la carte blanche
que m'a donnée jacques fournier pendant
laquelle j'invite trois poètes des
afriques amina saïd qui est une poète
tunisienne mais également véronique
tadjo tanella boni nous avons la chance
d'avoir une très grande chanteuse
algérienne qui qui a réussi à retrouver
des chants anciens des poèmes anciens
des aurès donc elle sera la folie aïchi
voilà elle ce sera le 9 mars à la maison
de quartier et théodore monod à
guyancourt
c'est un des rendez vous je dirais en
rendez vous africain de ce dessous temps
forts de ce moment pour nous important
un autre important ce sera le 18 mars
cette fois ci à la verrière à la maison
de la musique et de la danse là aussi
une soirée algérienne à laquelle ne
participera samira aux côtés de la la
peau est marocaine rimba talent mais
aussi du performeur camerounais belgo
français maximilien atangana et on
invite aussi un personnage assez
exceptionnel c'est abdel wahid al amana
qui est éditeur mauritanien qui vient de
publier un ouvrage remarquable qui
s'appelle le lignage l'histoire d'une
famille de cinq générations d'une même
famille de poètes mauritanien voilà et
on a plein d'autres rendez vous un petit
peu parlé le sens spirituel à retrouver
sur le site internet itinéraire poétique
sky point f
merci à tous les deux à tenir si venus
sur ce plateau nous parler de ce
printemps des poètes qui débute et puis
vous suivre l'actualité de ce printemps
des poètes bien sûr au cours de nos
différentes éditions
on change complètement d'univers à
présent nous restons sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines mais nous
allons aller du côté du technocentre
renault à guyancourt qui emploie plus de
dix mille salariés
rencontre avec le directeur du
technocentre philippe brice mme antier
nicolas landry nicolas kirillovitch les
résultats du groupe renault pour l'année
2016 sont tombés il ya maintenant
quelques semaines 13% de croissance plus
de 3 millions de véhicules vendus
et pour en parler nous sommes
aujourd'hui au technocentre de renault à
guyancourt en compagnie de philippe
brice montier bonjour félibrige montier
bonjour alors quel est votre
participation à vous le technocentre
dans ce chiffre d'affaires de renault
alors vous avez raison de dire la
participation du technocentre parce que
bien entendu les résultats de renault
sont les résultats de toute l'entreprise
l'entreprise en france mais aussi à
l'étranger à l'international et bien
entendu le technocentre à toute sa part
puisque vous le savez ici nous concevons
la gamme renault la gamme dacia dans
leur entièreté est donc bien entendu les
bons résultats commerciaux sont très
liés à ce qui a été conçu ici donc c'est
aussi très bon pour le moral des équipes
qui ont travaillé d'arrache-pied je dois
le dire pendant toute l'année 2016 et ça
leur permet d'engager l'année 2010 est
sous d'excellents auspices
alors justement l'année 2017 quelles
sont les perspectives de développement
peut-être des projets a évoqué alors les
projets c'est d'abord la continuité de
tout ce qu'on leur affaire en 2016 mais
même également en 2015 puisque vous
savez que quand on démarre un projet
véhicule ça dure pas une année c'est un
projet ça dure sur plusieurs années donc
nous allons poursuivre tous les projets
qui ont été engagées les années passent
et poursuivre le renouvellement de la
gamme même si il a été largement elle a
été largement renouvelé ces dernières
années et puis nous avons des projets un
peu emblématique qui seront
dans la route d'ici peu sur la route
d'ici peu comme par exemple le véhicule
autonome et tout ce qui tourne autour du
véhicule connecté du digital qui sont
des enjeux extrêmement fort pour
l'entreprise aujourd'hui en termes de de
concurrence à quel stade de
développement en est le véhicule
autonome justement alors le véhicule
autonome y roulent déjà il y en a même
quelques-uns qui roule autour du
technocentre
mais entre le moment où la voiture est
capable de rouler et le moment où elle
sera commercialisée il va se passer du
temps tout d'abord parce que la
réglementation est aujourd'hui pas
adaptées aux véhicules autonomes et qu'
il y a un gros travail sur ce terrain là
avant qu'on puisse faire rouler les
voitures
le campus de guyancourt le campus
automobile doit ouvrir dans les
prochains mois peut-être pour l'année
2018 qu'est ce que ça peut vous apporter
vous ce type d'établissement alors le
campus automobile j'imagine que c'est
l'établissement qui s'est créé du côté
du de la place des frères perret qui est
en travaux aujourd'hui encore pendant
une petite année aujourd'hui on annonce
que
ce sera un centre de formation
automobile donc c'est d'abord une bonne
nouvelle pour renault
j'ai pas encore eu l'occasion de
rencontrer les propriétaires de
l'entreprise mais nul doute qu'au moment
où les travaux sont presque terminés
nous aurons l'occasion de discuter
ensemble
je ne sais pas vous dire aujourd'hui
précisément de quoi sera fait cette
entreprise mais ce que je sais c'est que
si c'est vraiment de la formation à six
et de la formation pour l'automobile il
n'y a pas de raison que nous ne
travaillons pas ensemble
d'abord ça nous apporte au quotidien des
jeunes que nous recrutons et qui peuvent
venir aussi des universités autour du
technocentre
que ce soit les grandes écoles ou les
universités qui sont sur saclay où que
ce soit l'université qui se trouve à
saint quentin en yvelines
nous nous avons recruté 700 personnes
ici au technocentre et beaucoup
d'ingénieurs et cadres en 2016
nous recrutons environ 500 stagiaires
chaque année et également 500
collaborateurs en alternance donc voilà
on a énormément à tirer profit de tout
c'est de toutes ces écoles et
universités comment vous introduisez
vous dans vos recherches dans les
conceptions le développement de que vous
faites ici au technocentre
comment vous intégrer cette question
environnementale il ya plusieurs
domaines
il ya le domaine de la voiture et
domaine des moteurs bien entendu
nous nous appliquons les règles légales
et les normes évoluent donc nous devons
également faire en sorte que nous soyons
aux normes telles qu'elles évoluent dans
l'est dans les années à venir
et concernant le carburant le diesel
deux facteurs font qu'il augmente
aujourd'hui d'une part l'accord de
l'opep qui a été signé en fin d'année
2016 et d'autre part la fiscalité qui
est de plus en plus dure sur le diesel
comment vous vous positionnez dans vos
recherches dans le développement aussi
par rapport à cette question là d'abord
nous fabriquons des moteurs diesel mais
nous fabriquons aussi des moteurs
essence et nous fabriquons aussi des
moteurs électriques ne l'oublions pas
puisqu'on évoqué tout à l'heure dans
votre question précédente
tout ce qui concerne l'environnement
renault s'est engagé fortement il ya
quelques années sur le développement du
moteur électrique
aujourd'hui chaque année nous vendons
environ dans le monde
trente mille véhicules électriques est
ce qui n'est pas rien s'agissant du
moteur diesel et s'agissant des normes
ou s'agissant des réglementations bien
sûr j'ai pas d'avis à donner sur les
réglementations nous sommes là pour les
appliquer les normes évoluent nous
faisons en sorte que nos gens nos
véhicules évolué en même temps que les
normes fibre isme entier merci merci à
vous
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités pour
aujourd'hui rendez-vous elle lundi pour
une nouvelle édition
[Musique]